Hello, I'm William Zaloga
and this is a discussion
of the pathology of non
-neoplastic skin diseases.
This is my information
and if you're
here, feel free to
come to my office
from room 424F or
call or email me.
And these are the objectives.
We're going to look
at some acute inflammatory
dermatoses first. and I
list some here that will
be representative. Chronic
ones listed here, and
then ones forming blisters
listed here, and then a
couple of other disorders
which are very common or
important to understand.
This is a story view of what
normal parts of the skin are.
Epidermis, dermis
shown appropriately,
this more purple area
on this low power image
epidermis, then you got
the epidermis below that,
and the junction between
them is a dermal,
epidermal junction as you
can see on this high power
view, and then the
subcutis contains adipose
tissue you and fibrostoma
and blood vessels that
will extend up into the
dermis and epidermis.
Most superficial surface
stratum corneum and
then as the cells start
to lose their nuclei they
form the stratum
granulosum, stratum spinosum
is the largest layer
between that And the
stratum Basilar, where
you have your basal cells,
which are the cells that are
forming all the cells above
that as these cells mature.
And the dermal papulate are
parts of the dermis that
extend between what are
known as the reedee ridges,
and these projections downward
are the reedee ridges.
And the basement membrane,
you can just make out
right here the thin pink
line that these these basal
cells sit on at the
dermal-epidermal junction.
There's some language
that goes along
with skin histopathology
and pathology.
Grossly things will be
described as macules or
patches, papules or nodules,
and that's just a matter
of the different sizes,
whether it's a macular patch,
papule or nodule. Then
there's plaques and pustules.
Pustules are going to
be pus-filled, raised
lesions, and all these
vesicobula blisters, blisters,
bua meaning marker blister.
And then wheel, that's
very itchy, transient,
elevated lesion, but variable
blinding and erythema,
and that's from edema.
And these are some
histopathologic nomenclature that
will be used, acanthosis,
diffused hyperplasia,
dyskeratosis, abnormal
characterization of cells below
the strenum ranulosum,
hyperkeratosis, thinking of
the strenum corneum,
lentiginous, is monocyte
proliferation along the basal
cell layer, perikeratosis,
the cells retain their
nuclei within the strenum
corneum, that's and
called perikeratosis,
spongiosis, intercellular
edema within the epidermis.
Review of the hypersensitivity
reactions is a good idea
because many of the sores
are going to be associated
with different types of
hypersensitivity reactions.
I list some of the examples
for each one of these.
Type 1, remember,
IgE is associated
along with mast cells.
I list examples,
for example,
urticaria, anaphylaxis.
Type 2, and that will be
immediate reaction. Type
2 cytotoxic involves
IgG, IgM, and those are
going to bind to their
antigen and have a whole lot
of factor molecules and
cells activated that
will produce different
diseases that I list here.
Type 3 immune complexes
deposition cause inflammation.
I list some examples. Type
4 is delayed and remember
T cells are going to be
producing a cytotoxic effect
and that usually takes 24
to 72 hours to develop.
I'll list some examples.
So the acute inflammatory
ones that we'll talk
about that'll be representative
of these types of
conditions are urticaria
and the others listed here.
Urticaria is also
known as hives.
It's going to be a, what
I just described, type 1
IgE-mediated type reaction
with localized mast cell
degranulation. And these
are what hives look like.
Most of you probably
already know what those look
like, but they can be very
widespread or localized.
And these are very
poridic, very itchy,
and they'll come on
singly or in groups.
And they will form what's
called these wheels,
will be elevations of
the skin. That's due to
dermal edema. So histamine
is going to react with
receptors, increase
vasodilation, and get the
reels and the pruritus,
and come back to all ages.
The majority of patients
don't reveal exactly what the
underlying cause is, but
the lesions can develop and
fade within hours to a day,
maybe, and they can recur.
And those cycles can
last for months and days,
cycles of recurrence.
If it persists, that
may indicate some sort
of underlying disease.
For example, collagen
vascular disease
or maybe even
Hodgkin's lymphoma.
Pathogenesis. So mast
cell, it depends on whether
mast cells are involved and
whether IgE is involved.
If they are IgE and
mast cell involvement,
that's a type 1
hypersensitivity.
And that's upon exposure
to the antigen. when it's a
systemic reaction involving
a respiratory system, a GI
system, other parts, and
that's known as anaphylaxis.
If it's mast cell-dependent
but IgE-independent, that
means something's directly
triggering the mast
cells. For example, certain
drugs like opiates, antibiotics,
and contrast media can
do that. And so you'll
get what's known as an
anaphylactoid type of reaction
or pseudo-allergic type
of reaction in that case.
Mass cell-independent,
IgE-independent means
that local factors are
causing increased vascular
permeability without
degranulating mass cells.
Aspirin is known
to do this, but
the exact mechanism is unknown.
There's something called
hereditary angio-neuronic
edema, and this is rare,
but it is potentially life
-threatening. It's due to
a genetic mutation that
causes a deficiency of C1
esterase inhibitor, which
increases vasokinin and
produces these effects.
Here's what it looks
like. The biopsy is done.
What you see is no change
in the epidermis, but if
you look in the dermis, you
see extra spaces between
these collagen bundles
and within these lymphatic
spaces, they're dilated
and wide. Okay, and
the collagen bundles are
extraspaced, so that's a
dermal edema causing
spacing of those structures.
Acute eczema or
eczematous dermatitis is
inflammation with erythema,
edema, vesiculation, and
periparitis. It's a type
4, type 5 hypersensitivity.
It's T cell mediated. What
you'll see if you look under
the microscope is epidermal
spongiosis, which is not
which is intracellular edema
and there are different
types that are based on what
initiates the condition.
I think there's some
photographs here that show the
condition and how it affects
vocal flexural areas and
you know how scratching
is going to be one of the
triggers to help this
condition get started and by
damaging the skin and producing
inflammatory reaction.
So there's atopic,
allergic contact, primary
irritant, and then
something called
photoexamitus and other
drug-related types.
Let's talk about
the spongiosis.
Spongiosis is the intercellular
edema. So fluid is
pushing these cells apart
and And they can form small
micro vesicles due to
this, or just look like a
large portion of them are
separated from each other.
With scratching, the
mechanical shearing
can produce an
intraepidermal vesicle or
blister that causes
fluid accumulation.
Because of this
inflammatory process, you'll
see perivascular
lymphocytic infiltrates.
ectopic dermatitis is chronic
relapsing there's going
to be some sort of barrier
dysfunction FLG mutations
and immune dysregulation
and when this occurs
there's scratching there's
going to be a mechanical
trauma that is occurring
you know there's already a
barrier dysfunction so
there's possible pathogens
that are entering the skin
abnormally and causing
interclamatory response,
and that's going to lead to
scratching, which is going
to lead to more problems.
Most commonly in flexural
areas. There's an
increased risk for staph
aureus colonization.
In the chronic
phase, the skin can
become very thick
with fissures and
fibrosis, which is
not as lichenified.
And there's some
treatments that
may help with this condition.
Allergic contact type is
type 4 hypersensitivity
again. triggered by contact
with allergens. Common ones
I list here, for example,
latex, poison ivy, and
nickel, which is a common
alloy in inexpensive jewelry.
And for example, this
watch bands as a metal
alloy on the clasp
here that you can see
produce this contact
type of dermatitis.
So it's superficial, if
you do a biopsy you'll
see see superficial dermatitis
with a modern nuclear
cell, for example,
lymphocytes, macrophages.
Reactions without eosinophils.
So, irritant contact
dermatitis is non
-immunologic. It's a direct
chemical irritation, and
it's going to be dose
-dependent. So, there
was some chemical that
this person had on,
probably some clothing
that was affecting him.
Then there's
photoexamidus dermatitis,
UV-like hand damaged
skin and that
can be a trigger for
flares of eczema.
But also UVB radiation
can also reduce
inflammation, so it
can actually be a
treatment, but that's
in controlled doses.
Penithial multiform is
rare and it's self-limited
hypersensitivity. It's
a type 4 reaction to
infectious agents
and some medications,
some drugs. It can
affect all ages.
Common triggers are ******
simplex virus,
some others here,
and trimethoprim
sulfamethoxazole, sulfa drugs.
Other triggers could
be autoimmune diseases,
for example, I list some
here, IBD and lupus.
And here's a photograph
that shows some of
the lesions you might
see, and you can
see these are forming
sort of targetoid
lesions, what are known
as targetoid lesions.
Three concentric rings with
a dark, dusky center, as
you can see right here, and
that's epidermal necrosis,
then a pale edematous
ring, you see here on the
palm, then the erythematous
ring is the last ring.
They can have symmetrical
distribution over
the body, as you can
see here, and they
often affect the mucosal
surfaces as well.
Okay.
Importantly, there could
be multiple lesions,
but those lesions,
in order to be called
erythema multi-form
have to affect less
than 10% of the total
body surface area,
which is what erythema multi
-form usually does. If the
biopsy is done of one of
these lesions, what you're
going to see is what's known
as interface dermatitis.
The interface we're talking
about is the dermal down
here, epidermal junction, so
you see along the junction
inflammatory cells. You
see a lot of lymphocytes,
mononlupia cells, these are all
lymphocytes, you see
some macrophages, but
But you also see
these structures here,
which are dead apoptotic
lymphocytes, okay?
So they round up, and
then they lose their
nuclei, and then they
become apoptotic.
So those are keratinocytes
shown by the green arrows,
and then after they
degenerate, they leave these
spaces, or small bacules,
and you see a lot of
lymphocytes infiltrating.
You'll see some melanin,
what's known as melanin
incontinence, so as this
surface is damaged here,
the dermipodermal junction,
then some of the
melanocytes might spill
the melanin into the
dermis, and there will
be macrophages that
will pick that up.
You may see sloping
and blistering as well.
If it gets worse, affecting
more than 10% of the
skin or body surface area,
then it changes which is
its name, the Steven
Johnson syndrome, which is a
severe mucocutaneous reaction.
Okay, see a widespread
epidermal necrosis and
detachment, often triggered
by medications and infections,
sulfa drugs once again,
and clinically involves
skin, but also the mucosa
can involve conjunctiva, the
urethra, ******* regions,
and it will produce
these blisters and larger
blisters, known as boule,
with epidermal attachment.
And if they're rubbed
gently, then the
surface of that blister
will be disrupted.
That's known as a
positive Nikolsky sign.
If it affects
greater than 30% of
your body surface
area, that's renamed
toxic epidermal
necrolysis, or TIN.
And how do you manage
that? You stop the
medicine, and you provide
supportive treatment.
Prognosis for Steven
Johnson is about 5-10
% mortality and for
toxic epidermal necklice
it's about 30% greater
than 30% mortality.
Chronic inflammatory
dermatoses and these are this
is a list of representative
lesions or disorders.
Psoriasis that's an autoimmune
mediated inflammatory
disorder due to some trigger
that damages keratinocytes
and that activates
inflammatory cells. Once these
inflammatory cells are activated
they will release various
mediators which will cause
epidermal hyperplasia.
So you get hyperproliferation
of keratinocytes primarily
affects extensor surfaces
with scaly skin plaques
with a silver gray scale
over the surface and
erythematous border usually
starts between the ages of 15
to 25 but can start at any
age it triggers a numb but
it activates innate immunity
50 also have arthritis
associated with this as
well as psoriatic arthritis
clinically once again
you'll see the scaly plaques
that's the same image
as before but they can
have different morphologies.
For example here,
this is just another image
and it can also affect
the nails where you see
pitting of the nails.
There's something called
the Cogner phenomenon where
the lesions will appear in
areas that are traumatized.
Also there's something
called the Auspitz sign
where there'll be minute
bleeding points when that scale,
that silver gray scale is
lifted from the plaque.
Biopsy's done. You'll
see marked epidermal
thickening. As you can see
here in this blue box, the
epidermis is very much
thickened, but some parts
aren't. It's very much
thinned in this area.
So as to the
elongation of the reedy
regions shown in
this blue rectangle,
and you'll see
perikeratosis, which is an
abnormality indicating
that there's abnormal
maturation and growth
of the epidermis.
Perikeratosis is
retention of the nuclei in
the stratum corneum. You
can see something called
Monroe microabscesses
in the green circle.
So in the stratum corneum,
you can see perikeratosis,
but also small aggregates
of neutrophils,
and they'll form
tiny pus pockets.
Those are going to be known
as Monroe microabscesses.
then psoriatic plaques
will be thinning of the
epidermis or over the tips
so these are the dermal
papula and you can see
how they're extending way
up here and that's causing
thinning in these regions
in that area but thickening
generally overall.
Lycan planus is another
chronic inflammatory condition
characterized by
itching or pruritus,
purple, polygonal,
planar, papules, and
plaques. And it can
affect the skin, mucosa,
hair nails, follicles.
Typically, middle-aged
individuals are affected.
It's self-limiting.
It usually resolves
over the course
of possibly a few
years. Pathogen is
not fully known,
but potentially a
CD8 T-cell response
to antigens. in the
basal epidermis.
It's associated with
hepacyte hepatitis C,
although most cases
the cause is not known.
This is what it can
look like. Typically
affects symmetrically
the wrists and the
elbows, but here is
affecting the ankle.
One thing he'll see
is that it affects
the oral mucosa
in what's known as
which are right dots or
reticulated lines that
you can see on the
oral mucosa here, okay.
Histopathologically,
what you're going to see is a
dense band-like inflammatory
infiltrate, so these
are a lot of lymphocytes
that are infecting the
superficial dermis, and that's
producing what's known as
interface dermatitis, and it's
going to be right at the
dermal epitermal junction.
You'll see what's known as
saw-toothing of the reedy
ridges. So that's these
ridges that are coming down.
Normally they're
more rounded than
this. Here they're
forming a sharp
pointy projections.
That's not a saw-toothing.
You don't see Savat
bodies here, but those are
anucleate necrotic basal
keratinocytes and it's not
high power enough to
actually see those. Maybe if
you squint really hard,
you can see some of those
shrunken
red-orange bodies
that have lost their
nuclei and those are
apoptotic keratinocytes.
Hypergranulosis and
hyperkeratosis, the granular cell
layer as shown by the black
arrow is thickened more
than usual and there will be
a lot more stratum corneum
that's produced and pigment
falling into the dermis
known as melanin incontinence
and that melanin is
going from the damaged basal
air that melanin is spilling
over into the dermis,
that's going to be picked up
by the macrophages there
in the superficial dermis.
Seborrheic dermatitis is a
common clinical condition.
Dandruff is a common
clinical expression
of seborrheic
dermatitis of the scalp.
The cause is unknown,
but the result
is increased sebum production,
okay?
There's going to be
inflammation that's
going to be affecting
sebaceous-rich
areas, commonly of the
scalp and forehead.
So there's going to be
inflammation and it's
chronic relapsing inflammatory
condition, but it's
not a disease of the
sebaceous gland themselves.
Because there's increased
sebum production,
there's going to be
overgrowth of myalassezia
yeast forms within that
oil-rich environment.
So you get these scaly,
greasy, yellow plaques.
Histopathologically, you'll
see separation in the
epidermis between the cells
themselves called spongiotic
dermatitis, and there'll be
an overlying scale crust that
will contain nuclei, so
abnormal growth, possibly due
to the inflammatory response
and the increased production
of sebum containing
neutrophils and serum, okay.
Then there's the
blistering disorders and
here's a representative
sample of the blistering
disorders that would
be good to know about.
Types of blisters can
determine their cause. So
where the blister is
occurring in the dermis and
epidermis. If it's just
separating the stratum corneum
so out of the form of
the roof, then that could
be a friction blister,
maybe pemphigus foliaceus.
If it's just above the
basal layer, so the rest of
the epidermis is the
roof, that's an example of
pemphigus vulgaris. If the
entire dermis separates, then
that's could be an example
of blue as Pemphigoids
and we'll talk about some
of these lesions here's
Pemphigus vulgaris it's going
to be due it's a blistering
skin disease and it's
going to be caused by
autoantibodies they're going
to be the IgG type and they're
going to disrupt intercellular
keratinocyte attachment
within the epidermis
and that includes also
mucosal lesions patients
Lesions are usually in their
30s to 50s, and it's usually
benign, but there are
extreme variants that can
be fatal without treatment.
So it involves skin and the
mucosa. The oral
lesions usually,
well, commonly present
before the skin lesions.
The lesions are superficial
vesicles, so they
rupture easily. That's
what's known as a
positive Mikulski sign
that we talked about,
and you treat it with
the immunosuppressors.
Histopathologically,
you can see where this
lesion is and why the
Nikolsky sign may be
positive because this roof
is relatively thin and
so with gentle agitation,
that may rupture.
There's the lesion
is called suprabasal
because it's just above
the basal cell layer
which leaves some of
the cells poking up,
I guess somebody at one time
thought they looked like
tombstones okay so they'll
be immediately above and
then you'll get tombstoning
of the basal layer and
pulpitus vulgaris and the
antibody is against a protein
known as desmoglenes proteins
known as desmoglenes and
that's a subunit of desmosomes
those are the proteins
that connect keratin sites
together and this is going
to be an example of what
that looks like so this is
Desmoglen 1 rich keratinocytes
and you can see more
superficial less basal and
then the Desmoglen 3 you can
see that's distribution
and this is just an example
of the Desmosome and a diagram
that shows how Desmoglenes
will help hold these
keratinocytes together so if
you do a biopsy and use
something called a direct
immunophorescence microscopy,
you use antibodies that
have a fluorescent marker on
it that will attach to other
antibodies, and you're
looking for IgG deposits.
What you'll see is a net
-like pattern between all the
different keratinocytes, even
the ones that are disrupted
down here, and you're
usually seen at all levels.
And this is what it can
look like clinically.
You see these
blister formations,
usually older individuals.
oral lesions. Oh,
this is different.
Nope.
Okay. This is Pempagus
vulgaris. Okay. But it
looks very similar to
Bullis Pempicoid here.
It's a blistering
skin disease. Once
again, caused by
autoantibodies of the IgG
type. Usually affects
older individuals.
And it can affect the oral
mucosa, but the oral lesions
usually appear after the
skin lesions, you know,
versus pevagus
vulgaris type lesions.
Those are going to be
tense bullae, which means
they do not rupture
easily. Okay, so that will
give you a negative
Mikulski sign, treated with
the immunosuppressive,
and this is where the IgGs
are going to be affecting
the protein that
produced the blister, and
it's against BPAG2, which
is part of hemidesmosomes
down at the base of
the epithelium, the
epidermis right here,
hemidoposomes, and that
shows where BPAG2 is going to
be located and affected
by those autoantibodies.
So you get sub
-epidermal blisters.
Histopathologically, you
can see the entire epidermis
is lifted off and you have
this blister underneath.
If you use direct
immunofluorescence microscopy,
you're going to see
a linear continuous
IgG deposition of
antibody and that's going
to be along the dermal
-epidermal junction.
Negative Mikulski sign
and the next lesion is
dermatitis or pediformis
which is a rare
disorder which is itchy
it has urticaria, they're
going to be formed,
and grouped vesicles.
It mainly affects males
in the 30s and 40s,
and it is importantly
associated with celiac
disease, because those
antibodies in celiac disease
are IgA antibodies
that are going to be
against gluten, but
they're also going to cross
react with reticulum in
the epithermis. Okay,
so that's going to
produce sub epidermal
blisters. They're going
to be very itchy and
commonly affecting
extensure surfaces. Here's
an example of what
that might look like.
And these are going
to be the proteins are
affected. They're going
to be anchoring filaments.
below the dermal
-epidermal junction, and
that's where dermatitis
herpetiformis has a
disorder that's
producing these blisters.
What you see if you take
a biopsy is at the tips of
the dermal papulae, you'll
see collections of neutrophils
and a discontinuous
granular IgA deposits at the
tips of those dermal papulae
and that's going to be
anti-tissue transglutaminase
and anti-epidermal
transglutaminase antibodies
that are producing that and you
can see that on direct
immunoforescence microscopy or
at the tips of the dermal
papulae you'll get aggregates
of those antibodies that
are going be collecting.
Okay, so I have already
mentioned the neutrophils
that are going to
accumulate at the tips,
so you get those micro
abscesses, but you also
get all that antibody
deposited there as well.
So epidermolysis bullosa
is a genetic disorder,
but there are a lot of
different forms depending
on which proteins are
going to be affected.
The major points to
know about are it's
a You're going to
have fragile skin
that blisters easily
for minor trauma.
And mucosal involvement can be
involved, and those
can be severe forms.
Common features is
that blisters are
going to be formed
at sites of pressure
or trauma at or
soon after birth.
Okay.
And it can affect many
different components of
the dermis and epidermis,
keratin, laminin,
collagen, and there's
many different phenotypes.
Now, this is a
common condition,
it can be acute,
it can be chronic.
This is acne bulgaris,
what you'll see clinically
is shown in this
image here, this is a
particular severe form.
Now, this is virtually
universal in the middle
to late teenage years.
Males and females are
equally affected, but
males typically have
more severe conditions.
It can be exacerbated by
drugs, for example, steroids,
testosterone, contraceptives,
or occlusion of sebaceous
glands, for example, by
heavy clothes or cosmetics.
It can be familial, so
it's possibly hereditary.
There is a non
-inflammatory acne and
inflammatory, and both
types can exist together.
non-inflammatory types
include open comedones which
are known as blackheads
they have a central keratin
plug and that's due to
the oxidation of melanin
not dirt or anything or
closed comedones which are
known as whiteheads and
the keratin plug is trapped
beneath the epidermis in
that situation and then
you have inflammatory types
and you get erythematous
papules nodules and
custules and you can see a
lot of erythematous
papules on this person and
severe variance can lead to
scarring of the epidermis
cause is as it says here
likely multifactorial
a lot of different
things coming together
to produce this inflammatory
condition centered
around follicles okay
so one of the causes
could be formation
of that keratin plug,
which is going to block
the outflow of sebum to the
skin surface. Another one
is hypertrophy of those
sebaceous glands, and
that's going to be under the
influences of androgens
during puberty, which a
lot of this disorder will
commonly present itself.
And then there's a bacteria
called propionobacterium
acnes that colonizes the
follicle and converts the
lipids in the sebum to pro
-inflammatory fatty acids.
So these discoveries led
to the reasonable treatment
that antibiotics would be
helpful for elimination
of bacteria and isotretinoin
has a strong anti
-sebaceous action which
helps the condition as well.
Now, rosacea is a common
disorder of middle-aged and
older individuals, females
more often than males.
The cause is unknown,
but there is a high level
of an antimicrobial
peptide that's part of the
innate immune system
against bacteria, fungi,
parasites, and viruses
known as catholicidin.
And so maybe there's
an infectious seriology
which may drive some
of the treatments
that are attempted
for these individuals.
There's four stages and
these are shown here with
flushing, then you get erythema,
telangiectasias, pustules,
papules, and then rhinophyma,
which is permanent
thickening of the nasal skin
by erythematous plaques.
Erythema nodosum is an unusual
inflammatory condition.
the sebaceous adipose
tissue mostly of the lower
legs and shins. As you
can see here it looks
like this person was maybe
just in a tough difficult
soccer match and didn't
fare so well however
this is subcutaneous
adipose inflammation and
these are going to be
raised erythematous
painful nodules
and plaques. The
triggers are going
to be infections,
drugs like contraceptives,
and some medical
conditions like sarcoidosis,
IBD, some neoplasms.
They can have systemic
sinus symptoms like fever
malaise, and the treatment
for this is going to be to
understand what it is, but
to treat the underlying
condition as well. It usually
resolves on its own, or
if it's painful, some anti
-inflammatory medications
may be used. And if the
biopsy is done, you can see
that within the subcutaneous
tissue, you have these
islands separated by
fibrosepta of islands of
adipose tissue, and that's
surrounded by inflammatory
cells. So you see
monocytes and macrophages,
along with a lot of
lymphocytes, infiltrating the
adipose tissue and also
the fibroseptas as well.
and so that helps make your
diagnosis and here is uh
the feedback form i appreciate
your feedback and thank
you for your time all the
best of luck on your studies